> POAE
P SENIOR ADV A SOURCE TELLINNHEM
TH
IN TRUMP'S
WITH MNOW IS
IS FORMER SI
THE SOUTHERN RKND L
OU MAK
>> FIRST OF ALL, THIPERSON, ER
ARTORS SE .EP FROM THE FIRSTTODS
SORT OF THE ULTIMATE
LE
A GRL SUU CANNOTUS OFF.
JANUARh NS OUT YWOTE T FFINALLYD
TON GEORGIA, OUT
OFD I THINK  TLY OUT OF THE J
ONGOING AND  SAIN VE MUCH
INS WE'RE SEEITHBPNA>> AND ELIE
BEALN
GEL N FOASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FOUNE
T ITY OF TRUMP INDICTED.
IT VINRE
TCH.YO A FORMER IDENT?L THAT
COUNTRY, WHAT KINDENT
UNDERSTAT THIS INO
SERIS. YOU HAVORRYTHOSE THINGSDS
FACTORS WILL INCLINE THE
ADIN
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO SEE HI
DOAK
THISILL DOGENE
JE COMPARISO A
TAKE INTO ACCOT  E MNDFOER. T
ANLE, ITDO MIGHT BE
N.THECORNO,
REASONA WAATN LFINT OSTHINGS, TO
DECISIO
OR PAS
SO THE R
LAYINGK IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
CONCLUDEERARLAND ITHESE THINGS,
FORGES A ON SORT OF THE
AWHINGOSECUTS OF
>> HE'S HINTED AT THAT ALONGO I
T GUCONSPIAULAO BUILONLINE ALL.
HERE'S WHA HE WANDCUFFED AND WA
W, EY'LL HAVE T ME FIRST.
I HA NGH AS YOU KNOWFOER
VES RELATE THE
SACHEME, PRESIDEXTENTATE  SO HO
JIM.
THIS IS NOT JUST THE
HYPOTHICRST OF ALL, LET'S REMEME
IN A FEDERAL  OCO.
HE HAD HIS TRIALAND HE'S
T
W T
POTETH
AT LEAST 30 DAYS.
NOW THIS CHARGE COMES ON TOP
AYS LOOKING
AT SER.LTIL
AND IF YOU LOOKORT IS